[Music]
the secrets behind during salmon is in
the flavor you're curing it with for a
hint of the exotic and aromatic my
favorite starting point is to grind
coriander seeds coriander seeds our
citrus it's got that nice orangey flavor
and it goes brilliantly well with salmon
top mix that with your salt and your
sugar it may look like a lot of salt and
sugar but once they've done their job of
cold cooking or curing the salmon most
of it will be washed away next the
grated zest of two oranges fresh pepper
and then mix in one of my favorite
ingredients grated beetroot beetroot
gives a really nice sort of routine
earthy flavor great for curing it stains
salmon as well and it just elevates it
now you'll see what's happening now with
a beetroot the salt and sugar breaking
it down see how wet is becoming now that
beetroot is ready for the Sun I forgot a
big party 10 or 20 get a whole side of
salmon fill it it and get it pin bone
buy a fishmonger if it's six or ten
guests and this chunk in the middle is
like the sort of middle part of a first
day the best of the best
pour on your beetroot and basically what
we're gonna do now sort of pack it with
all the beetroot and look at that I mean
it looks fantastic next cover your
beetroot II salmon with cling film take
your tray
lightly press and they get something
substantial something heavy a pot or a
pan or some tins the weight on top just
speeds up the process
place your salmon in the fridge to cure
for at least eight hours or even better
overnight
now to unveil my incredible beetroot
cured salmon offer the weight betray and
look what's happened to the salmon
absolutely beautiful you can just tell
how delicious that's going to be with
this sort of Sheen give that a little
rinse in cold water with your kitchen
roll Pat it nice and dry beautiful
[Music]
traditionally cured salmon would be
sliced into large thin pieces like
smoked salmon but I like to cut mine
into thin strips it's easier and it will
show off its beauty slice down get to
the skin and then flick your knife out
that for me is a much better way of
eating cured salmon through the
difference of colors that nice dark rich
ruby red now when you've got cured
salmon this good trust me you just need
a salad melba toast or some stunning
bread look how many slices of salmon
we've got that's the secret for me do
any good party
come masterpieces simple straightforward
ingredients are done properly
[Music]
my son chose beetroot cured salmon